hi i'm larry elder this is the dave
rubin show obviously i'm not dave rubin
i'm more likely known as the black face
of white supremacy by another times
columnist whose initials are erica d
smith oops
dave has been gone for an entire month
and my job
great deal of pressure is to go over
every major event that's happened the
last month and get his reaction to it
but dave first tell us what you've been
doing for the last month well first off
larry it's good to see you my friend i
it's been a while
it has been a little while last i saw
you was in
last time you saw me we're both
californians now now you're stuck i'll
turn out the light though when i leave i
am free in the free state of florida in
miami where we're at right now and i
should mention real quick that we are
debuting the local studio here in miami
right at this very moment right so
you're hosting the first show right here
in the local studio um
i have been gone for a month oh but real
quick your intro is very nice there
because i like that you had to say that
you were not me in case people thought
you know i go away for a month i can get
very tanned that's right next thing you
know and we often wear very similar
wherever you go people are going aren't
you are you mary elder which one are you
again
anyway yes i have been gone for a month
100
i know nothing that has now understand
you don't
you know nothing you didn't walk by a tv
set you didn't cut on the radio you
didn't pick up a newspaper you know
nothing at all what's going on i know
last whole month so this is the sixth
year that i've done this off the grid
thing and the first year that i did it
it was ju it was a joke really it was
just like ah let me just put my phone
away for a month see what happens and
then it was it was pretty great and you
know i get to sort of reset my brain and
think about things a little bit
differently and you know we're in this
political thing it's burning hot all the
time and i wanted to just see if i could
cool it off a little bit and then it's
really been great over these years now
this year obviously was a little
different than my other years where i've
gone to the rain forest of mexico or to
bora bora and disappeared and stared off
into the edge of the world you got some
big news for us uh i am now a father
larry elder that's right uh justin was
born uh we
early hours of august 6. he was supposed
to the due date was the 22nd so i
thought we were gonna go off the grid
and we'd have a couple weeks right enjoy
ourselves and you know we'll eat good
food and we'll go to the beach and
everything will be great but five days
into off the grid thing we got the call
and justin is here i'm a dad it's been
it's been something you know it's i've
been peed on more this month than at any
other time in my lifetime literally if
you took all the other times i was
beating up this time literally yeah
exactly um
but it's been it's been great you know
i'm a little tired i gotta ask you about
that um uh i have friends of course who
have kids i do not my brothers do
and everybody everybody everybody tells
me it's changed their life instantly in
ways that they never imagined so the
same question for you how to change your
life what did you think would happen
what has happened you know
it's weird because so usually i feel
very refreshed when i come back right so
i have a month off and i feel refreshed
i don't feel refreshed right now i feel
i feel renewed which is different right
like i don't feel refreshed like i got a
lot of sleep right and i just like i'm
like fully like bam let's go i feel more
like i actually feel
i feel the responsibility of what we do
is is heavier on me now like now when i
look at him it sounds corny it really
does sound corny um but i feel like wow
i'm not just fighting now right to save
a world for myself
or for david or for you or for nina it's
like now i have this kid who i want to
make the world as good as possible for
him so he has been surrounded by an
awful lot of love we've had a lot of
family
my folks david's parents sisters
brothers uncles cousins my sister who
lives in miami had a baby a few days
later it's just been baby palooza and up
all night and you know you got to feed
these things
like every two hours do you know about
this
it's a lot um so it's so it was easy to
be off the grid this time the only thing
that was different because i was
basically locked at home except every
now and again someone would tell me you
got to go get diapers you got to go get
butt paste you got to get whatever you
know aquaphor blah blah blah
it was very easy to be off the grid
except i did have my phone this time so
i wasn't on social media but usually i
just locked my phone away but this time
in case there was an emergency or
you know that i had to go pick something
up or i was getting a lot of phone you
know congratulations and all that stuff
so it's a little different this year
um
but i feel good and i feel ready to be
back in on it well two more things
before we get back in on that um i heard
a rumor that uh your son may have a
companion at some point uh yeah
in the near future i'm not quite sure
where i heard that yeah we got another
one coming in the middle of october
supposedly due october 14th but i have a
feeling he's going to come a little bit
early so we'll do it all again
but you got to say don't i look pretty
good considering you know
you always look good but all my friends
every time they have a baby you see them
like three days later and and the men
aren't the ones that carry the child i
don't know if you know that but somehow
the men well i'm not a biologist but i
have heard that the second one is this
but the men all look horrible right
because every nobody's sleeping reading
so i it was my responsibility this month
david and and my mom and his mom they
were handling a lot of like the
nitty-gritty and i changed a couple
diapers and yes i truly was peed on he
pooped on me several times it's a lot
right
but
um i felt if i could keep our life in
order like make sure we were like
sitting down to eat and make sure the
house was clean and all of that stuff
and going to home depot and blah blah
blah second oh yes another second major
question yes what exactly is butt
you heard that term before
you never heard about about that sure i
want to know almost everything i've been
discussing in the last week is butt
paste if a kid gets um diaper rash there
are many treatment options available
butt paste is it's that's the brand name
and this is what it's called it's called
butt paste and it's old school and it
comes in this little jar and it's just a
paste for the butt that's more
information than i think i want to know
about so larry did anything happen did i
miss so i honestly i have no idea wait
let me just say one thing so the one i
don't know anything other than he was
born on uh we went to the hospital on
the fifth he was born early morning on
the sixth when i got to the hospital a
lot of the nurses there and staff knew
me and and security people and other
people and a bunch of people kept saying
you don't know about the thing you know
like they were like kind of jumping at
me so i feel like something happened at
the beginning but i truly
phrased it you don't know the thing is
that how they put it because well i
hated it because they knew that they
weren't supposed to tell you anything so
and everyone that i went up to when they
were trying to say hi to me or take a
selfie i was like i was like just
remember right i don't know anything so
yeah everybody was respectful of that
even when i saw people when i'd go to
whole foods or i went to home depot or
whatever people would be like so you
still don't know you still don't know
and
yeah nobody blew it nobody so i know
nothing yeah i have it i have as you
know your staff assembled this long list
of things
chronological order uh the last month uh
but
something happened that is so big i
think we ought to start with that okay
um but before i start i want to say this
there's a lot of pressure on on the
person sitting in
for you to ask you stuff because
how the news is delivered will shape how
you perceive it which is why we're so
angry about the left-wing media cnn msnb
hee-haw abc nbc cbs they hate trump they
don't like republicans they're happy
with high taxes they're happy with soft
borders and through that filter comes
their news
i'm a trump guy uh i believe that
there's two tiered systems of justice uh
i believe trump was probably the worst
treated president in my lifetime and it
is through that filter that i see
everything so i feel a responsibility to
give you the news in a fair and in
balanced way so you can react to it
properly as opposed to reacting to my
own biases so i sense you're about to
tell me something about trump is he
running that well uh that's not what i'm
going to tell you about i'm confident he
is going to run i'd be shocked if he
didn't okay okay so i don't know
anything anymore anybody else knows
about that but maybe he announced but
there was there was an fbi raid and
mar-a-lago
uh a warrant was taken out uh a warrant
is uh supported by an affidavit uh and a
judge a u.s district judge his name is
bruce rinehart executed a warrant uh and
at 9 30 or so in the morning uh around i
think it was the eighth or so of this
month of august about nine or ten fbi
agents swarmed in on mar-a-lago and went
through the trump residence and removed
about 15 boxes of information
at first we didn't know what they
removed
trump wanted the list of stuff revealed
he wanted the warrant unsealed and
revealed
and then he wanted the underlying
affidavit unsealed and published all of
which ultimately happened and these are
all unprecedented for the warrant to be
revealed let alone the underlying
underlying affidavit and that's to
protect the in the investigation uh
that's why they don't want it revealed
and apparently can i pause you for one
second just to understand the story so
so they raid does it immediately break
that they did it or did people find out
later like did people know that day it's
hard to say when it broke but it broke
it broke fairly quickly yeah keep in
mind trump has uh cameras everywhere
he was not there right trump was not
there melania was not there he was
elsewhere but he was watching the raid
apparently uh on video and that video
has not been released yet but he was
watching it uh his son eric found out
about it contacted his dad and told his
dad it was going on
when this happened exactly i can't tell
you but the news broke within hours or
so of this of this raid so they
basically just busted in if he's not
there i mean that's right they they they
went in um they were armed um and around
eight or nine agents came there
and um this was
never happened before and based on the
revealing of the warrant revealing of
the underlying affidavit revealing of
commentary that i of people i respect he
is accused trump of having probable
cause to violate the espionage act by
removing
information pertaining to national
secrets national security from the white
house when he left the white house he's
accused of
violating an act that prohibits you from
destroying
sensitive government documents and he's
and he's accused of lisa's probable
cause that he committed obstruction of
justice
apparently 15 months ago or so
there was some back and forth about
documents that he removed and some of
them were
returned and it appeared that they were
voluntarily they meaning uh the fbi the
national archives working with trump
lawyers about what he took and normally
when a president leaves the president
often takes documents that are perceived
to be documents he shouldn't have
removed and you work it out right this
was not worked out and a lot of people
feel that
there's a double standard here it should
have been worked out uh garland gave a
statement unusual after this happened
because half the country was was was on
fire not on fire physically which is
angry
and said that um
we always try to get these things
resolved in the least invasive fashion
and he suggested that donald trump was
being difficult uh refusing to turn over
documents he should have turned over so
we had no choice but to do this
and god this sounds like just such an
extension of all the stupidity
so i wait so
they're accusing him of taking a bunch
of stuff so they bust in there they take
the documents have the documents been
running would you say i don't think they
knocked down a door but i think they
knocked on the door at 9 30. uh nobody
got a heads up trump's two of trump's
lawyers were there but they were not
allowed in to witness a search but they
were in in the house when it happened
they weren't allowed in to witness this
no so they can just basically the fbi is
this how it uh it's supposed to operate
they can just basically get into your
house take all your stuff no one's
allowed to win
there's a warrant allowing you to search
certain places and uh apparently they
even searched melania's wardrobe
okay so i would imagine uh a lot of
people are not happy about this i would
imagine trump is fighting this i mean
what's going on
uh trump uh is now demanded that they
appoint a
a marshal an independent marshal to go
over all of the documents
underlying the warrant and to make sure
that what was done by the fbi is on the
up and up that's also unusual so trump
has filed a motion to have an
independent third party
take a look at everything the fbi did on
that day to determine whether or not
they should have done it man they really
don't want this guy running for
president like
that that what else could this possibly
be about like does he really have
documents there that he wants well
that's technically that's unclear and i
tell you somebody that i look at a lot
when these kinds of things happen
because i think he's fair and that's
andrew mccarthy on fox
he's not a trump guy but he doesn't hate
trump and he's a former u.s attorney
and he wrote a very long piece that came
out a couple days ago in the national
review and said trump probably took
documents he shouldn't have taken trump
trump probably was uncooperative trump
probably made public statements about
whether he was cooperative when in fact
he probably wasn't
uh and there may be an indictment
forthcoming uh accusing him of violating
the espionage act violating the act that
i said earlier that forbids you from
destroying government documents and
accusing him of obstruction of justice
he now believes that there may be an
indictment coming alan dershowitz angry
about the whole things feels that there
won't be an indictment feels that this
is double standard elder fills its
double standard right for a couple of
reasons hillary as you know
clearly violated the espionage act she
had a unchanged server basement
bleach bleach on which she sent and
received information that was classified
denied that she did turns out she did
and then later on she said that um she
never sent or received information that
was stamped is classified she lied and
said and turned out she did and as you
know james comey did this big
presentation and talked about how
careless she was how reckless she was
but the last minute he said but she
lacked the intent right well the
relevant part of the statute dave does
not require intent and so a whole bunch
of us right and i can't just do a bunch
of bad stuff and not having and then you
have eric holder eric holder was under
his opinion to turn over documents
pertaining to fast and furious that was
a gun walking thing that
for some reason the government did
presumably to trace where these guns
were going and the bus the cartels for
buying these guns well the guns got
loose and at least one of them was used
to kill a border patrol agent and so
eric holder was subpoenaed by congress
to turn over the documents he didn't do
them didn't do it he was found in
criminal contempt of congress the first
and only a.g to be to done to have done
so republicans took him to court and
over the course of five years holder was
able to negotiate back and forth
ultimately turned over the documents we
think
um and okay so wait wait wait i get the
double standard right one more one
sandy burger remember that one uh that
was he was bill clinton's national
security advisor and uh congress was
conducting hearings on whether or not
bill clinton this is before night after
9 11 might have known something or
should have done something to have
stopped it so berger goes to the
national archives steals documents right
stuffs them in his pants gets busted and
got a slap on the wrist and so these are
just three examples where in my opinion
if we were being consistent uh they
should have been punished far more
harshly hillary wasn't punished at all
and as you pointed out destroyed a bunch
of uh documents around the subpoena
youth bleach bit bleach bit yeah and got
rid of all them and nothing happened to
her so even if donald trump my long way
of saying even if trump took documents
he shouldn't have taken even if he's
uncooperative how is it you came down on
him with a hammer and those guys got to
pass right so okay so the double
standard thing that's just standard
stuff right we we're used to this you
know you're on the left you're gonna get
the pass you're in on the you know it's
basically a mafia game where if you're
all in on it together you let your
people off and you always go for
everybody else so is the country just
insane right now i mean basically when
this happened i now i assume that just
lit a fire under magga and his msnbc and
cnn saying wait are the walls closing in
on the guy the walls are closed
these are freaking walls we got
yeah that's exactly what you're saying
and is this story still burning hot
right now because you said what'd you
say on the 8th or so 8th or 9th
something like that it happened about
about a month ago not quite a month yeah
okay and right now the issue is whether
there'll be some independent uh
magistrate or marshall or forget the
term to look at all of this to determine
whether or not it should it was fair if
you talk if you cut off they want to
make him jesus if you cut on cnn you cut
on cnn and cut on msnbc all their
lawyers say donald trump should not have
taken these documents uh was outrageous
for him to take the documents this is a
guy who does not play by the rules and
uh he got what he did what he deserves
do we know what any of the documents are
though like do we actually know okay
there is a document in there that had
some secrets
there was a list of all the stuff that
was taken out uh although the affidavit
underlying the warrant was heavily
redacted i mean you look at the sheet
there's a bunch of black stuff all over
there so you're not sure exactly what it
is they were looking for or what it is
they have um but um it does not appear
that
um
we still know we still still we don't
know does this feel like all the others
to you like the impeachments like it's
just like a show or the january 6th
thing like the show must go on but
obviously nothing comes of it like this
as you're telling me this like that's my
gut feeling
this is where i feel feel the pressure
on me yeah i want to make sure i give
you enough information so that you can
respond to it uh in a rational uh dave
rubin-esque way um i think i've given
you all the information so the answer to
your question is in my opinion yes it's
the same stuff it feels like they
despise this man
uh they're not giving him any leeway you
know trump does not dot all the eyes
across all the t's uh he often says
things that turn out to be
exaggerations i mean that's how he is
yeah i've always said this and and it's
not original to me we meaning people
that support trump take him seriously
but not literally the people hate his
guts take him literally but not
seriously and that's to me what's going
on here
so
i mean people think there's a legitimate
feeling that he could be indicted which
would send him to jail i've always said
uh that i bet my house and since i live
in la and and given and given the
homeless encampment not too far
maybe you don't want it but i always
always said i bet my house he will not
be indicted i still don't think he will
be but i never would have thought that
they would have executed a raid on
mar-a-lago either so i don't know
anymore i still if i were a betting
person i would say he's not going to be
indicted so he asked me if the country's
on fire that's what the country is
waiting for if the man gets indicted
senator um
from north carolina linda graham said
that he believes it would be riot in the
street he said that and a lot of people
reacted to what he said um i believe
that that's the next shooter drive the
election that happened if that happens
that happens there will be an explosion
in the country in my opinion so that's
what people are waiting for right now
wow you know it's funny so right before
i went off the grid as i say every year
but i really meant it more so this year
just because of the general state of
chaos and we haven't even talked we
haven't mentioned brandon yet but like i
wasn't even sure if he was going to be
president when i got back i assume he is
if that's the biggest story um but i i
said right before i left i was like
there is nothing that would surprise me
that there would literally be it would
be almost impossible for you to sit me
down here and say something that would
be so off the rails you know short of
the alien invasion or the zombie
apocalypse which wouldn't have been that
crazy to me either um but this this
feels a little bit more like just like
the standard this is what these guys do
so i think my gut reaction is just sort
of non-hysterical because
this is what they do we went through 18
impeachments we went through the january
6 farce like i'm not saying i have no
idea obviously i'm just hearing this now
but it's like maybe he took some stuff
he shouldn't have and yeah is he a
little sloppy and across the t's and dot
the eye stuff
sure but like does he have secret
documents at the country club in west
palm like and this is what's going to
get him and is he trying to undermine
and is he trying to undermine the
country
is he taking documents out because he's
selling them to the russians i mean what
exactly are you suggesting here and he's
fighting this like trump style like a
full-on
fight fight fight right and his lawyers
have been on television and one of them
said that we were cooperating and then
all of a sudden the cooperation stopped
and they went in they didn't have to do
this uh uh we could have worked it out
why didn't we why didn't they give us a
chance to work it out that's interesting
i wonder if they thought that he was
going to announce a run over the summer
and that's why they did it because i
kind of felt i didn't want to say it
right before i went off but i kind of
felt he was going to announce in the
summer so that he would be first in keep
the media always about him right and
then also take credit when hopefully
unless you're going to tell me something
else crazy here we get a massive red
wave in november that he would basically
be like see i announced republicans
crushed
i'm orange we're red let's roll speaking
of which and there's a lot of people i
want to get to but speaking of which wow
all right so after this raid uh and
trump by the way calls it a raid and the
fbi does not call it array they call it
a search
so
it's like insurrection resurrection riot
the polls show that the percentage of
republicans who want trump to run in
2024 went up
that doesn't surprise me and the polls
show that the percentage of people after
these 9 11 televised hearings
who believe trump is responsible for the
riot went down
so if the goal was to weaken donald
trump as a candidate in 2024 regarding
the televised hearings or to weaken him
as a candidate regarding this raid on
mar-a-lago it backfired you know it's so
obvious when when you step away from the
news a little bit and then i hear a
story like this like it's just so
obvious to me how badly cnn and msnbc
and washington post and new york times
they need him they need him way more
than he needs them at this point like
i'm sure their ratings are pretty good
right now right like people are paying
attention you know pretty good relative
to what they are right so it's like
they're not fox ratings but like people
are paid they need hysteria they just
need that endless source of hysteria
anything better than they need trump and
i've always maintained one of the
reasons the media so dislikes him is
because when he ran in 2016
they thought of him as a joke they put
him on msnbc they put him on cnn and the
ratings went up yeah but they did not
think of him as a serious candidate so
no harm no foul numbers go up we can
have some fun with him laugh laugh
behind his back and then little by
little of course he began picking off
his rivals and they realized they
created a monster and they were
determined now to undo that you
mentioned ratings uh while you were gone
brian stelter
got fired
the media guy on cnn yes are you kidding
me jeff toobin wait got fired
when they brought him back now
he brought him back
you know they brought him back after he
brought him yeah he ever after he took
out his tuba all right all right
nobody's perfect
new yorker by the way fired tuban on the
spot
and uh cnn suspended him brought him
back but he came back before you left
wait wait wait wait wait put two bit
aside stelter is out delta's out gone
gone wow and they did it yeah they did
it they did it there's a new ceo who
says he once wants cnn to get back to
being fair fair and balanced as if they
ever were right uh and we're late for
that and he's apparently cleaning house
he had a little meeting
the new cnn his name is
shocked i mean he had a meeting and said
nobody is secure we want to get back to
not being perceived as a left-wing
network i'm paraphrasing yeah and then
within days of that meeting brian
stelter was gone
and they gave him a week or so to say
goodbye yeah which was a mistake because
he teed off on the new owners they are
just their discovery right and the ceo
and and teed off on on that guy uh and
then jeff toobin also got released
wait stelter first off what's
interesting to me about that is like he
sort of became the worst of the worst
you know he's supposed to critique the
media right and you know you're probably
are you friends with howard kurtz at all
or he must have done your show did a
show when i ran for because he had the
original reliable sources before stelter
and i remember watching that when i was
a kid i was always interested in media
and politics and that stuff and it was a
good show on sunday mornings and then he
just stelter just
became the worst of the worst like
giving everyone what you think they want
all the time and the internet must have
loved requiring memes must have been
incredible remember when the hunter
biden laptop story broke of course
stelter was one of those out front yeah
we're not questioning russian
disinformation
uh
all the hallmarks russian disinformation
and uh went off on how fraudulent the
story was and of course it wasn't
fraudulent and he denied that he did
that when the tape was all over the
place no he is the embodiment of why a
lot of us dislike cnn but
as far as i'm concerned don lamont is
every bit as bad if not worse because he
proposed to be a news guy at least
stelton never pretended to be a news guy
he was a he was a commentator a critic
and why don lemans does the job is
beyond me remember during jossey
smallette
turns out don lemon
called him off the record and told him
that the chicago police did not believe
his story uh and gave him a heads up a
news guy is not supposed to do that and
later on that that came out and nothing
happened to don lemon
so
that well none of that surprises me and
my guess is that lamont's head is on the
chopping block too and probably a few
others we'll see but but
since this guy since the new ceo has
been in office but we've been running
the place by the way about six weeks now
their numbers have gotten worse
really yeah so it's so irreparably
damaged the nuclear meltdown it's begun
already the core meltdown there's
there's nothing they can do the new york
times there's nothing they can do you
step away from it for a little bit it's
so obvious these things are in their
death rows and what's interesting about
a guy like stelter is like stelter has
all the opportunity in the world right
now right you're more surprised that
stellar being fired than the mar-a-lago
raid
well the wall emily just feels like yeah
the next trump adventure it's like the
adventures of donald trump you know it's
like harry potter and the blah blah blah
it's just donald trump and the raid on
mar-a-lago okay here we go stelter
though what's interesting is
i'm guaranteeing you this guy is not
getting another decent job like he's
done
and he has nobody that's going to
support him like here we are in the
local studio because a certain amount of
people support me certain amount of
people support you there's such a like
an incredible uh fertile ground right
now for people that are interesting to
to get out there and get some he'll get
another job no he'll get some crappy
throwaway job but i'm saying no no real
people he'll support him he'll go back
he'll go back to washington post or
he'll go back to msnb
which brings up another thing that
happens
um i made a joke and i said something
about uh what's the over under on
whether msnbc hires delta first
or liz cheney oh my god liz cheney lost
her primary oh she did good well that
that's yeah good great
let me ask you what was it a bloodbath
by how many points do you think she lost
it
so i like harriet hageman and i had her
on the show and i was very impressed
with her how many points i mean oh my
god was it was it more than 10
37
she lost by 37 points that is the
biggest loss of any incumbent uh running
for reelection
uh in a primary this century
that is in the largest one i've ever
heard of 37 points but but i thought she
was the moral face of the republicans
and cheney gave her
a concession speech in which she said
she's going to spend the rest of her
energy making sure that donald trump
never approaches the white house again i
i guess except as a tourist maybe wait
wait so i'm guessing she said that so
i'm guessing now msnbc and cnn
everyone's saying that she'll be she's
going to run for president probably like
that's got to be the next step oh she
was sort of too good for that she
certainly implied it
and then she was interviewed and and she
said something to the effect of they
don't want to see me on the debate stage
with donald trump well as far as i know
in order for you to get on the debate
stage you have to agree to support the
eventual nominee and the whole point
about her running is to make sure that
donald trump does not become the nominee
so i'm not quite sure how she's going to
navigate that but there is speculation
she may run for president yes good god
well that's good that's good because
she's she's nothing you know it's like
what i always call these people they're
pet republicans the sort of mitt
romney's or liz cheney's these people
who go on msnbc they say exactly what
you want they never conserve anything
they never accomplish anything but they
get pet on the head you know they give
them a cookie after the appearance and
then they get to come back in a week or
two and then the washington post says
nice things about them as opposed to l.a
times calling you the black face of
whites and you know what gets me about
people like romney and cheney romney as
you know ran in 2012. harry reid goes on
the floor of the senate and flat out
lies and says the word in the street is
the man has not paid taxes in 10 years
because the time
romney didn't want to turn over his tax
returns and then a few years later harry
reid's interviewed and he admits he
knowingly lied
and when dana bashes cnn asking about
that how do you feel about that he goes
well he didn't win did he so you and at
the time the polls showed that romney
was probably going to beat uh
obama who wanted to be reelected and so
what harry reid did was basically
torpedo
romney's chances of becoming president
fast forward he now hates donald trump's
guts and chaney uh her dad dick cheney
as you know was vice president under w
and just a few years ago he was called a
war criminal by the very people that are
now embracing liz cheney so i don't
quite understand it no but because she
wants in on the machine you know like
it's it's pretty sexy if you can get in
on it if you can sell your soul to that
degree the same people you will sell
your soul to the same people who were
trying to destroy your father and your
family name and everything else but
i guess the constituents are a little
wiser than liz well that is saying wait
can we pause for one second because i
just realized
i mentioned to you right before we
started but it's worth mentioning again
that a year ago right now september 1st
you were running for governor of
california just to talk about how a year
changes so quickly and how everything
flipped so quickly you were running for
governor we were campaigning together i
think on september 2nd or 3rd i i was at
an event with you right uh somewhere uh
about about half hour 45 maybe modesto
or something um and then obviously the
recall did not go the way we wanted and
then two or three days later i was done
i was done with cali you're still in
cali we're now in florida like things
man what a year you know what are you a
whole bunch of people told me had i won
they would have stayed yeah i a lot of
people told me had i won they would have
come back
and so i would have stayed obviously so
the exodus has accelerated after that
what a year back at cheney for six yes
sorry
you said she wants to wants to join the
machine it turns out her net worth since
she's been in congress has increased
substantially now she has a husband as a
pelosi style she has a husband who's a
partner at one of the major law firms
latham and watkins but her own personal
net worth has also increased three or
four-fold and nobody can kind of quite
figure out why she owns a lot of stock
uh as you know many people who are in in
the house have been able to take
advantage of inside information i'm not
saying she did it all i'm saying is that
there was a big story about how her net
worth has increased pretty substantially
man all right so so far this is so far
this is pretty interesting so we got the
trump raid i have to obviously ingest
that a little bit more stelter getting
the boot right is spectacular i don't
wait the thing is i don't wish ill on
people but he's not someone that should
be respected or listened to so go do
something else go be a potato farmer you
gotta get going you just can't stay here
so him out tubing who cares it's like
all right whatever i'm sure he can get a
job on uh what's that site uh only fans
or something
he wouldn't do well but
and then this liz thing so okay we're
getting rid of some people some some
people seem to be moving out of the way
the brush is clearing what else you got
for us with that smile on your face
speak speaking of brandon uh oh yeah
brandon has still doing it tested
positive for covet again
right now he's yeah and then and then
after a few days he went into isolation
and they said he was negative and tested
positive again
good god
you know remember what happened right
before i left the grid just a few days
before was when he accidentally said he
had cancer and everyone was like no no
no that's just because he has dementia
like that's the level that we're dealing
with with brandon i didn't hear his name
once actually the only time i heard his
name the entire month is we've been
doing some construction at the house and
my my contractor is annoyed he calls him
brandon because the supply chain is so
screwed up that you know you can't get a
screw because of brandon basically you
can get screwed because they're branded
so wait so he has covered for now the
18th time yeah but and what about the
fumbles and the mumbles and everything
like is he just still doing those
uh any big signing i think there are two
major things he's done that you should
be aware of yeah the first is the uh a
sort of skinny version of buildback
better has now been passed mansion and
cinema both conceded okay and a bunch of
money uh hundreds of billions of dollars
of money uh is being spent uh
eighty-five percent of it which is for
climate change but it's called the
inflation reduction act
uh yes because spending a whole bunch of
money really helps right
you gotta admire it you've got to admire
the evil right and even bernie sanders
said that this bill is not going to
reduce inflation even bernie sanders
said it
so a bunch of money hundreds of billions
of dollars more
the second thing he did is that he is
through executive order apparently
um there's still some details left but
going to forgive up to ten thousand
dollars in
student debt
for people making under 125 000
or for household making 250 could be as
high as 20 000
and the lion's share of it i mean it's
just nonsense the lion's share of it is
going to go to people whose incomes are
at or above the national average or will
soon be at or above the national average
because they went to college right and
so people that didn't go to college or
people who went and paid their own loans
off are not happy even some democrats
are not happy right well you're
punishing people for doing the right
thing i remember very clearly when we
paid off david's final uh college loans
it was a great moment we worked really
hard he had loans for years and finally
we were making some money a couple years
ago we paid it off it was great it's
like why pay it off and also what do you
say for 100 150 grand 125 000 under
singles but if you're a household you
can forgive up to 20 grand i think these
are people that have pell grants and so
the idea is these are people who are on
the lower end of the economic spectrum
but
the people that went to college and the
reason you go to college is to make more
money uh are either at or will likely be
at above the national average in salary
and so people that are below that are
not happy larry i'm not a constitutional
scholar and i've been a little off the
uh the beaten path lately but i'm pretty
sure the founders didn't think that the
president would be able to sign
something which he doesn't even sign
it's like an auto pan or something right
so that someone's debt who voluntarily
got into debt to do something whether it
turned out to be good or not and often
at 125 grand that means you could get
out of college be making a hundred grand
a year which is pretty decent you went
to duke where you spent all this money
to get in you're subsidizing actually
upper middle class people in many cases
right you're not just subsidizing the
the the kid from the inner city who goes
to community college god and regarding
and regarding the legality of this
stupid everybody in july of last year
nancy pelosi said during one of her
press conferences that the president
lacked the legal authority to do this
right of course
after biden did it she extolled the
virtues of the bill
the general counsel of the
secretary of education under barack
obama also said recently that he did not
believe the president had the legal
authority to do this so
it's already been being sued being
challenged in court and it's going to
work its way up to the supreme court
probably do they ever even think of the
secondary effects of this stuff it's
like you can't just erase it it still
exists you could say oh you don't have
to pay it but the debt still exists do
they care somebody right somebody's got
to carry you remember one one obama used
to say he didn't have the legal
authority to legalize a bunch of illegal
aliens and didn't daca anyway
so remember aoc she said you don't have
to be factually correct you have to be
morally right morally right god [ __ ] so
all right so this is hung up in court
though and i'm gonna guess actually that
correct me if i'm wrong i got one here
for you i'm gonna guess that the loony
progressive side is saying he didn't do
enough right like they're probably
actually you're right the naacp is
unhappy because they feel a disportion
of this will go to white people to white
people in fact i've called it
reparations
for rich white people uh lawrence tribe
is a law professor from harvard yeah he
tweeted this is great news for my
students now who went to school who i
taught are now going to be relieved of
ten thousand dollars so
people that went to harvard law yeah
insane are going to be relieved of 10
grand of debt says lawrence tribe god
that the mission they just want the
machine to continue so much of it when
you step away is just about the show
must go on the stupid show must go on
they must get more money with the bills
that they sign and so our republicans
let me just back up to the to the first
building we were talking about the scale
back bill back better are republicans
all did any republican oh no so
obviously some republicans voted for it
right some
not not in the senate not in the senate
so nobody so but but mansion and cinema
came over that was enough yeah and
that's where we're at on this that's
what we have the inflation reduction act
yeah that's what's called the inflation
reduction act yeah uh and by the way uh
joe biden's poll numbers appear to be
doing a little better because gas prices
have gone down a little bit
and in july uh there was zero percent
inflation that one month
and biden that's interesting
press conference said inflation is now
at zero it's not it's yeah it was zero
in july year to year eight point five
wait but was that a flub or just a lie
uh was that just one of his like he
doesn't know what he's saying if you say
inflation did not go up in july it's
correct yeah right right but inflation
year to year went up 8.5 yeah and and
year to year for gas prices up almost 50
percent
so
people are still hurting yeah and it's
still the number one issue
it's interesting because here in florida
i thought maybe
that i would be able to gauge what's
going on in the country just by the
amount of people that are out and about
or just you know when you go into stores
but everything's so flourishing here
that everywhere i go things are packed
there's so many cars on the roads the
stores are all packed the restaurants
are all packed but i know florida's not
the the sort of perfect bellwether for
the rest of the country um going through
some of these a republican
member of the house name is jackie
walorski
indiana
was killed in a car crash
and
the she's 58 years old
and the controversy
is the way the new york times did her
sort of obituary
one of the first lines was
she
uh
supported what happened uh when donald
trump has been denied the election i
basically called her an election denier
as opposed to the first line going over
her career her life and what happened uh
uh
uh representative wolorsky kama who uh
was one of those who doesn't believe the
2020 election was on the up and up comma
blah blah blah god it's so gross i mean
that when you when you make politics
about everything then it's just so gross
that they do it's not a newspaper that's
what people need to understand these
things are not
new york times by no estimation of what
we old school folks would think of as a
newspaper all the news that's fit to
print right it's not that cnn is not a
news organization even if this guy fired
stelter like that type of thing that
that's just so gross that that doesn't
surprise me um but you mentioned new
york times new york times has not
endorsed a republican for president
since 1956 is that that was four years
old
who was it do you know who it was uh 56
that would have been eisenhower jeez
that's it yeah that's it so uh you know
mondale over reagan really yeah the
caucus over george herbert walker bush
really were you on the uh when they did
the sunday cover about the people on
youtube that are leading people to the
alt-right and it was me and jordan
peterson and milton friedman and shapiro
were you i'm not sure i was i don't
think did you not make that one i think
i would have known damn i did make the
cover of newsweek recently oh you did
yeah
uh
it was about it was about uh i then came
out around the time of my election and
i'm sitting in a chair kind of like this
like the godfather and there are four or
five other republicans standing around
me including winslow sears candace owens
um the whole crew and jones and one or
two other people yeah
i don't remember that
uh back to this uh the congresswoman
that
died and how they are phrasing her as an
election denier here's what bothers me
dave want to get your reaction to it
for four years
when trump was president hillary
referred to him as having been
as illegitimate her word not mine and
called the election stolen
there was a thousand page report about
the 2016 election the senate did and
there were two major conclusions now
conclusion number one is it's going to
keep moving conclusion number one is
that
the russians tried to alter vote
tallies but they did not succeed in
changing a single vote tally
yougov poll came out in 2018
66 percent of democrats believe the
russians quote
altered vote tallies close quote to
elect donald trump even though there's
zero evidence they altered a single vote
uh jay johnson his uh dhs secretary
testified under oath obama's secretary
under oath that
not a single vote tally was changed yet
two-thirds of democrats believed that
they were
the second major finding is uh jay
johnson said we have no idea whether the
russian interference altered the outcome
of the election we have to be mind
readers to know that we know they tried
we don't know where they had an effect
on public opinion we don't know whether
or not it affect on the outcome 78 of
democrats according to the gallup 2018
believe that the russian interference
quote altered the outcome of the
election close quote my point is a
greater percentage of republic of
democrats believed 2016 was stolen than
we believe that about 2020. yet hillary
is not called an election denier
uh
stacey abrams who still claims that she
lost her election because of fraud uh is
not called an election denier
al gore who still claims that the
supreme court put
george w bush there it's not called an
election denier hillary's not called an
election denier her platforms have not
been shut down even though their
analysis of 2016 has caused so many
democrats to falsely believe the
russians changed votes you know it's
interesting because
basically you're getting back to that
double standard thing again and in some
ways you know for this whole month it
was a lot of baby stuff for me but when
i would sort of think about how i want
to do the show going forward and how i
want to have a new take on things and it
had something to do with this because
this the double standard thing it is
never going to stop
people need to understand that we can
expose it a lot of us do a hell of a job
exposing it you've been doing it for
years on the radio obviously i've been
doing it now there's shapiro and rogan
and all these people exposing the
nonsense right but the nonsense is never
going to stop the machine sort of needs
the nonsense it needs the lie it needs
it it launders lies through the system
and then you get a certain amount of
people like a liz cheney or say a
jennifer rubin who is not my sister or a
bill crystal these people who used to
kind of make sense right but then they
realize the system never loses the house
never loses so then they want to get in
on it so it's a much
i guess it's a little more
a little more scary to be on our side of
it to know that for whatever reason this
force just exists
and and it's going and going and going
and you're always fighting it but i've
been really trying to think in the last
month like how do i want to go ahead and
and do the show and it's like you have
to call attention to it and you have to
hey you know they would do it this way
if it was our guy and this is how they
do it for their guy but also not get
completely obsessed by that because
because you can't win
what they do what they say is you're
engaging in what about israel yeah yeah
i hear that all the time i said no i'm
calling out the hypocrisy i'm calling
out the selective outrage i'm calling
out the double standard for example
benny thompson is the chair of the
january 6 committee he's the one
chairing these televised hearings
january wait is that is that [ __ ] still
going on oh yeah it's still happening
yeah they think they didn't they they
put a pin in it and then they said we'll
have season two
they've stopped it but they are implying
there's one more to come
anyway because trump didn't trump grab
the driver and then yeah
explosively and then and then one of the
secret earth agents said it never
happened but benny thompson is the chair
of the january 6 committee yeah
and in january of 2005 after
george w bush won re-election
they challenged the certification of the
electors in ohio
and he joined 30 democrats to argue that
the
election in ohio was fraudulent should
be set aside arguing among other things
that the debuff voting machines were
rigged because diebold i think the ceo
was republican were rigged even there's
no evidence of that so he was engaging
in wait for it election denying
here he is sharing the hit sharing the
hearings it's just what they do you know
it's like if you think about the way
that they've treated the squad right
these are all heroes and they're such
empowered wonderful women and then what
happens that woman myra flores wins that
seat in texas right and what is she in
the new york times what's the article
called the rise of the far-right latina
right sound a little familiar to
something they used to do to you yeah so
it's like it's just it just is what it
is and we just have to we just have to
keep building new things and and
separate from these people i i really
believe that this is not on your this
this is not on the list of topics i was
given but you just remind me of
something yeah one quarter of the squad
is illan omar yeah who of course wants
to defund the police
she called the cops because somebody
apparently was at her with on her
property hiding in her trash can
and she called the police
so she kind of wanted them to come to
her rescue when she needed them but she
wants to simultaneously defund the
police the same people that she has
demonized endlessly have basically
destroyed we don't want to use the h
word hypocrisy yeah remember that when
she uh she was calling for defunding the
police they're ruined they're literally
burning down right minneapolis and then
she gets she does that press conference
from a gym somewhere at a school and
she's like the police aren't doing their
job and it's like man you people your
governor uh has been hit in the campaign
trail yeah and he has been supporting
people that the critics have been
calling election deniers people like
kerry lake
uh in arizona who i also support it by
the way she won so desantis is
supporting kyrie late right all right
great and she won her primary yeah oh
good and is in a a tough fight for for
uh for governor yeah but desantis being
criticized for supporting quote election
deniers in various other races around
the country so if you support somebody
who is skeptical about the results of
2020 you in fact have now been infected
by the same disease and you're an
election tonight denier as well i'm
going to go out on a limb and say that
ron desantis doesn't care about that and
he's going to keep doing what he's doing
i assume things are going well here in
florida is he still basically the
president i mean he basically is the
functioning president he's still a rock
star he's sort of the leader of the
country at the moment yeah he's still a
rock star yeah um the mass mandates have
now uh uh come back
in in certain areas certain areas so i
have not heard a thing about it i i
covet has nothing to do
with my life right now like literally
nothing to do with my life at any level
whatsoever fauci apparently is going to
retire at the end of the year
okay with the highest with the highest
pension any government employee has ever
had close to half a million dollars a
year until he dies
he's the highest paid federal employee
right he makes about 420 grand a year
yeah and he's never going to die so
right they've been rejecting him with
all sorts of stuff he also got wait wait
in certain areas philadelphia
speaking of which i got to tell you
about this little things going on in
philadelphia yeah yeah not on the sheep
i want to get your reaction to it yeah
um
there's a amusement park called sesame
place have you ever heard oh yeah i used
to go there when i was a kid i've been
there many times climb on those ropes i
had never heard of it yeah i'm in l.a we
have
disneyland yeah uh you got universal
studios yeah uh something you're a
burbank guy yeah and uh
not berry farm any other things but i'd
never heard of sesame place
and it's in pennsylvania i think right
outside philadelphia yeah okay so
there are muppets characters that that
run around oh god and the character name
rosita you know that is that's the green
one with with shaggy stuff rosita let me
guess she's trans
no um there's video of rosita going down
a little street where the kids are going
like this cheering as she's going down
the street
and she's high-fiving
white kids but they're little black
girls that want him to high-five and he
and and rosita ignores them
i mean it's pretty blatant if you okay
so look at that surely strikes you yeah
coming down the road like okay like a
parade right and on the sideline you
have all these people and these and the
characters highlighting them
by the way you don't know who's
underneath the costume it could be a
male could be female could be black
could be anybody you don't know right
but these little black kids were ignored
okay and the parents of the black kids
put it on youtube
and then other parents who'd gone to
sesame place
put other instances on youtube where
their kids were were ignored by the same
character by the same character okay so
this sounds like something seems
interesting here maybe we don't we don't
know let me guess it was a black woman
in there no we don't know we don't know
who's uh we still don't we still don't
know it's still a mystery right now wait
why don't they tell us who rosita is
twenty-five doesn't even matter 25
million dollar class-action lawsuit
filed by a family from baltimore
whose kids were ignored
oscar already lives in the trash now
they're going to sue them for 20 years
sesame place puts out a statement
apologizing profusely offering the
family that whose feelings were hurt the
lifetime passes
and but jesse jackson sends a letter
demanding that they all undergo
sensitivity training
that there be at least one black member
of the board of directors
and they do they do more business with
black vendors
jackson says nothing however about the
fact that in baltimore the city where
these kids were from
13 public high schools zero percent of
the kids are math proficient
another half dozen only one percent is
jackson did not write a letter about
philadelphia on track for more homicides
in their history and almost all these
homicides are black people
so that didn't cause jackson to write a
letter but he wrote a letter on behalf
of the families that allegedly were
dissed by rosita so you're saying
there's a little more publicity in going
after elmo than say dealing with
crime
schools yeah yeah
well obviously we must know the racial
makeup of rosita to have a better
understanding of the story because if
it's a white person it's racist if it's
a black person maybe they're confused or
colorful or self-loathing self-loathing
or blackface the white supremacy are
people saying it to you are you rosita
now
uh as you know uh
uh george lloyd uh died uh because of
what derek shoving did big trial derek
shulman was found not guilty
a few days ago
there were three
arkansas police officers wait sorry
derrick chopin was found guilty right
yeah
okay not guilty i think he's not healthy
although i will tell you that um
it spawned four months as you know of
riots in in the streets right they were
mostly love intolerance 25 people were
were killed or more about 2 000 officers
were injured and it is estimated that
about 2 billion of damage was done
zero evidence that whatever you think
about derek shelvin and i believe that
the verdict was just that he did it
because of eric
of george floyd's race the the black
prosecutor leaned over backwards to make
sure in his opening statement
that he said police officers in general
were not on trial minneapolis police
officers were not on trial this
individual was on trial and he never
argued that that children were motivated
by george floyd's race yet there were
four months worth of protests in the
streets all presumably because they
believed that george floyd was a victim
of police brutality because of his race
three or four days ago
there were three arkansas cops i forget
the name of the town
beating the crap out of a white suspect
the cops are all white and um the
suspect allegedly we don't know because
they didn't show the video ahead of time
but the suspect allegedly attacked an
officer body slammed an officer and
there were three officers on top of this
guy just beating him beating kicking and
beating begin kicking him
one day story yeah
i'm surprised it even made a day still
one day story yeah yeah there were about
10 million views on youtube but on cnn
and msnb
one day story man that's the double
standard thing again and it's just like
it's something we just have to like you
just basically have to swallow it
understand it know that it is and that
right like where wouldn't black lives
matter care about police brutality
regardless of skin color if your main
issue for two years we were told the
whole country or for more than two years
but you know they're driving force of
that movement when they weren't burning
down the local mom-and-pop nail salon
and shoe repair place was that this is a
systemically racist country and police
are evil so if police were beating the
crap out of a white guy wouldn't you
still care about that if you really
cared about larry i'm starting to think
these people are full of [ __ ] what do
you think man is it just him i just
would've been gone one day story i'm
seeing it clear my mom used to say he's
just a dead fly and the guy's alive he
wasn't killed
but he was beating the snap out it was a
rodney king s kind of beating although
it was just three cops and not uh not
however many they were with rodney king
right uh show business yes
you know ann hayes
uh
he's not ellen's wife she was ellen's
wife she was elegant like divorced or
yeah whatever okay she's dead oh she was
in a car accident
uh apparently she was on drugs and this
is in an area of l.a called hawthorne
she was driving and she plowed into
another house
uh and she was killed
the no one in the house was killed but
she was taken out on the stretcher this
video and she died a few hours later
apparently 53 53 years old and
apparently full of drugs fentanyl
including oh clean fentanyl
man i mean well i'm sorry to hear that
but the fentanyl thing i don't know if
there are any major story well i guess
this is a major story about that but
that is like the big problem in america
on the horizon if people aren't real
olivia newton-john uh died
so i did have a feeling that that was
the one thing that i thought maybe
happened because
uh when i was flipping through like
apple movies at night and on spotify
there was a ton of olivia newton-john
stuff and i was like they only show you
that kind of stuff if someone died so i
did i thought either she died or like or
it was the 50th anniversary of greece or
something like that right that's that's
sad staying in the show business mold uh
alec baldwin as you know alec baldwin
shoot now
what now by the way when i was running
for governor alec baldwin tweeted larry
elder uh is dangerous i mean trump
dangerous so i tweeted back and i said
how many people have i shot and killed
just in round numbers he didn't he
didn't he didn't respond
i'll tell you one uh alec baldwin story
i don't think i've ever said this
publicly before but you're you know that
place craig's in la yeah it's a very
famous it's like where you go to to be
seen right or this restaurant in west
hollywood which is why i never go right
so i've i've only been there once right
i've been i don't know i've been there
twice i've been there i knew it when i
finally signed my first deal my agent
took me there and then i went i went one
other time anyway so the second time i'm
there um this is before alec baldwin
shot that person or some of the stuff
but this is maybe like six years ago or
so i'm at craigs and the way the whole
restaurant is because it's to be seen
there all the booths are sort of in a u
so that everyone can see everybody
because that's the whole idea you want
to see people in the paparazzi rosa alec
baldwin came in and he's with his wife i
don't know her name but the maybe
they're still married blonde woman
he was screaming at her and getting in
her face in a violent manner like i have
never seen before ever publicly like it
was so designed to be seen and make sure
everyone knows they see because it's all
it's all celebrities there and it's in
the past every time every time they open
one
and he wanted them to report on him
yelling at her i think so like wanted
just that he he wanted everyone in that
place to look at him and see him and
blah blah blah did it work was there a
story on it i don't know that there was
a story on it but everyone in the
restaurant was looking at him everybody
oh it's alex oh look at the way he's
young like it was embarrassing he was
embarrassed but i did see steve
guttenberg there that was pretty good
what's he doing now i don't know but he
was having dinner
that
i'm just saying police academy man i
love you um wait so what happened the
reason i mentioned it is that for
whatever reason the fbi did some sort of
report uh uh investigation on whether or
not he pulled the trigger he
ball went on a couple of occasions once
to i call him george clintonopolis
stepanopolis told stephanopoulos i would
never pull a trigger on a gun i would
never do that i've never pointed a gun
but he did didn't he of course he did
and so the fbi did some sort of analysis
and said actually you did and you pull
the trigger and and the gun and the
bullet went out and you're the one
responsible for having killed this um
she a set designer uh
cinematographer or something right i
mean the whole thing with that story is
ins look i don't think he's a murderer
in a in a traditional sense murder like
get charged with anything right i don't
think it's like that i also i don't know
the exact um policies related to on set
when they hand you a weapon but i'm
pretty sure when you're on set people
you assume he broke the policy so i know
i guess the policy
somebody didn't follow policy right so i
guess the policy is you have to check
yourself but i would imagine that actors
think about all the movies with all the
guns you think you think sly stallone is
like flipping through the chamber every
single time he's shooting something like
you know so there's a lot of blame to go
around uh twitter um
god please so twitter more than anything
what do you think that i'm gonna say
about twitter
well i'm guessing nothing happened with
elon musk unfortunately that would be my
gut feeling is that that thing just
fizzled out i think
maybe it was intentional i was saying
this months ago
as much as i wanted him to get it i
thought maybe he was intentionally
trying to expose the nonsense knowing
that there's so much fakeness there i
will tell you this
uh having not been on social media for a
month i mean first off i don't miss any
of it absolutely none of it i miss this
i miss doing the show i miss like the
reaction with my with my real fans that
sort of thing
and and i love this i really do
twitter is the one like i don't know if
i want to get back on there
i'm starting to think
that i've been thinking it for a while
like just let it go it's evil and it's
so highly manipulated so i don't know
what you're about to tell me please tell
me they discovered something about the
algorithm or did or did there was a mass
banning or
am i even on twitter no i first
responded to some of the stuff you just
said uh
when i ran for governor i was just a
smidge under a million followers yeah on
twitter i remember we were always happy
when you and i first met yeah you had
about 50 000 more more than i i did and
i thought if i can stay even with dave
and then of course she just took off so
it left me in the dust but i had a
little under a million yeah
and
as soon as i ended the campaign over the
next several weeks i lost almost ten
thousand yep almost twenty thousand
little by little by little began losing
them elon musk announced his intention
to buy
twitter blows up i gained about i got a
thousand i got 10 000 within 24 hours
yeah and uh and then when it looked like
he was backing away because he claimed
that uh he was sold to bill of goods
that there were way more bots than he
understood
all of a sudden i began losing again
um so right now where it stands is he's
taken them to court or twitter's taken
him to court to force him to go through
with his 44 billion to buy the
fraudulent company yeah and there's now
a whistleblower who's come forward
and said that we at twitter have no idea
how many bots there are
it is not in our best interest to know
how many bots there are they have no
mechanism to find out how many bots
there are and so now it looks as if uh
the argument that elon musk made has a
lot more strength behind it now i'm
going on the assumption the
whistleblower is now being called an
alt-right conspiracy theorist and alex
jones we don't we don't like yeah we
don't know who the whistleblower is but
uh i i think twitter there's something
about what's going on on twitter that is
that is way more obviously evil than the
other stuff the other ones you know it's
evil like you post something on
instagram and it's all full of bots and
they're trying to get you to click this
link to buy bitcoin or like nonsense
twitter it went from there was this
feeling like you could really share a
message and think you could see you
could watch things go viral you could
see it right now i just don't see like i
i haven't been on twitter in a month but
i like basically never see your tweets
anymore now does that mean that they're
shadow behind and i tweet a lot but but
does that mean they're shadow banning
you to everybody or do they actually
pick who they want to see who because
they know what nodes are are able to
then get other people's messages to
spread it's like this is what i kept
thinking all month with twitter because
i really i'm feeling this thing you know
jordan got jordan peterson got booted
from twitter because he said that ellen
page was a woman or elliot pages i don't
know whatever the hell he said doesn't
matter he's not he's not trained
biologists yeah he's not a woman what is
he he's a psycho
psychiatrist not a biologist
psychologist but um
you know he stayed off twitter he could
have deleted the tweet and come back and
as far as i know unless he came back
this month with him which i think i can
say with confidence he has and it hasn't
uh there was a feeling because i got
booted when i then defended him i
basically just screenshot what he said
right and i decided to come back because
i wanted to be in where the fight is but
really it's like playing monopoly
we're all basically playing monopoly
knowing that the guy in charge of the
bank is stealing money and we all keep
losing and every night we say let's play
monopoly again
he's the banker with the money yeah and
we just keep doing it and that's what
has to shift that's what has to shift
that's why i built a studio that's why
that's the thing about the it's like the
double standard thing to get back to
what we're talking about earlier it's
like that's something it is real
it exists it ain't going anywhere right
what can we do
to move off it i don't know that i can
play that game anymore something feels
very very obvious solution is for us to
have our own mechanism our own platforms
indeed are on google
uh because uh truth social which is yeah
which is the platform that donald trump
has built uh is now not going to be
carried on android google oh they're
booting them from android that's
interesting it's almost 40 of the market
so he won't be able to speak to a lot of
people that really you know i'm not a
i'm like you i'm i'm mostly a
libertarian as you know you know this is
where if the government can't
ensure that there is some basic ability
for companies to compete right then then
i don't even know what the purpose of
the government is like now that google
has become more important than the
government if they say your store
you will not be allowed to be in the
marketplace that is the marketplace
right and now they're saying you can't
be in there well and i gotta say truth
was i was getting good traction on there
it felt real to me the way twitter used
to feel because i got on there a little
bit before well this leads us to another
very important topic i can imagine
people watching this live on our live
stream going ask him about this ask
about this what you just led into it we
talked about twitter yeah big story
uh on the joe rogan podcast
he is interviewing mark zuckerberg no
[ __ ]
no [ __ ] he did it already uh i'm
laughing because
i'm tempted to respond in kind my father
hated it when i cursed i hated it and i
used to do it much more freely than i do
right now yeah
once in a while we went off camera
my father used to wince when i when i
would curse and so i worked on it and
now i've got to the point where i don't
do it anymore now you're going no
wait he did it already they did the
interviewer okay did the interview
already okay very long interview you
know as you know he's linked the link
the interview is kind of like shocked
yeah
and he of course asked mark zuckerberg
about the hunter biden laptop story
which which uh which uh facebook and
twitter both suppress twitter uh didn't
even retweet the story on the new york
post shut down the new york post's
ability to do it and facebook also
altered the algorithm so that far fewer
people saw than otherwise would have
yeah and zuckerberg says and i'm
paraphrasing this is very important how
he phrased it
he said
some people from the fbi
came to us
or came to some members of my team
and said
that there's going to be some
wow some stories that are going to be
dropping pretty soon
and it is likely going to be russian
disinformation
and we want to give you a heads up
they do not specifically say there's
going to be a story about hunter by
laptop
but within days of the fbi coming to
zuckerberg's people zuckerberg said that
the laptop story dropped
we assumed again i'm paraphrasing we
connected the
warning to the story and that's why we
suppressed it
uh rogan followed up by asking did they
specifically talk about the hundred
biden story he didn't say it quite that
way he didn't say quite that well
frankly he should have i was critical of
the interview and i tell you why in a
second yeah
zuckerberg said no but they told us
there's going to be russian
disinformation as there was in 2016 says
the fbi and we should be wary of that
and so when the hunter biden story broke
i thought that's what the fbi was
talking about referring to so that's why
we suppressed the story
wow and he admitted he zuckerberg
admitted that they alter the algorithm
so that it didn't get the name same kind
of coverage that otherwise would have
and and uh and use the word meaningful
meaning that percentage of people who
did not see it was meaningful
so first let's so so just getting back
to you about being a libertarian yeah
it's one thing for a private company to
make that decision it's another thing
for the government to essentially
warn you knowing full well that you're
going to take the warning seriously and
so it makes it almost state action now
right so at that level so in essence
what you have is the government
outsourcing the tyranny the government
is basically saying here it's a threat
if they're calling facebook there is
some level of a threat involved there's
some stuff coming down the pike that if
you promote
you might have some other problems we
might want to audit you or all sorts of
stuff so so that's where they are
outsourcing the tyranny they're not
stepping on the first amendment directly
well this is sort of like uh remember
when saki said over what was it was it
last summer when saki said that the
government flags certain posts for us
well
uh
uh you know we flag certain posts for
for facebook i should say it's like this
has been happening for a long time so
when did this happen this zuckerberg
interview is this last couple days last
last 10 days maybe last 10 days so are
people
hopefully realizing what's going on here
like
again
any of our robots the npc's our side
meaning the non-woke side is reacting
exactly as you as you have just done
surprised
but the others aren't saying a whole lot
uh because there was a study that was
done by a media research group and found
that 16 percent of joe biden voters say
had they known about the hunter biden
laptop story they would not have voted
for biden so it clearly altered the
election but something altered the
election even bigger and one of the
reasons i was critical of joe rogan's
interview is he didn't bring this up
you know about the 400 419 and a half
million dollars that zuckerberg spent of
his own yeah zuckerberg to bring out uh
democratic turnout yeah uh molly
hemingway wrote a book about it called
rigged i'm sure you talked about i saw
her right before uh right before i went
up right i interviewed her and um
uh citizens united did a documentary
about it still online you can watch it
for 40 minutes we talked about how
zuckerberg strategically went to
election officials in places where there
were a lot of democratic votes cleveland
detroit atlanta
philadelphia to gin up democrat turnout
now the idea was that he was being a
good government guy
uh and some money was spent for
republican turnout as well but like
maybe 10 and 90 for democrats so clearly
he did it to tip the scale in favor of
democrats
rogan did not mention it
and a two-hour interview did not raise
it
that's interesting how do you do that
how do you how do you not have mark
zuckerberg in front of you yeah and not
bring up it's like
am i talking to the wright brothers not
not missing airplanes or him before not
missing cars right or o.j simpson not
mentioning he killed two people maybe i
cut took
how do you not ask him about the 419
million dollars of your own money that
you spent
on the election in 2020 how do you do
that
he didn't ask it i'm going to go back
and watch it for sure the only thing
that i can say slightly in rogan's
defense on this which just as an
interviewer and you know this too
sometimes over the course of an
interview you're doing something and
especially if it's live and you don't
edit that you want to get back to
something and it just doesn't present
itself that's not really like a
full-throated
excuse or something because he should
have hit on that but but putting that
aside you know what's interesting about
this is remember jack dorsey from
twitter
once the new york times said that the
hunter biden laptop was real jack dorsey
basically who doesn't work at twitter
anymore so when he was running it he did
all the bad [ __ ] now he doesn't a pardon
my french yeah he did all the bad stuff
he said we shouldn't uh but but now that
he doesn't run it anymore he says we
shouldn't have done it now
years after the election result that
zuckerberg wanted now he can kind of
sort of admit there was government
pressure to do something
and it's like how many times will we
continue to play monopoly with a bunch
of people who own all the hotels on park
avenue who we know are rigging the game
right
that's the question yeah i guess maybe
that's that's my number one sort of
public basic question but again getting
back to rogan um and i and i have
respect for him i think he's a good
interviewer and he's clearly very
popular did rogan put you on when you
were running no
years ago he reached out to me to have
me on the show we went back and forth it
never happened but since then i've heard
heard nothing
i'm digressing yeah
when i i just did a two-hour interview
with um c-span
and somebody called up
and black guy and he said
uh i've watched your career why is it
you never go on this show or this show
or this show like i can just show up
knock on the window and say hey
interview me yeah uh and he's and i and
i mentioned charlemagne the god
i was on a plane once and a guy named
bill bellamy he felt like a fellow
fellow comedian yeah um meaning you
fellow comedian uh was sitting next to
me and we started talking and after a
while he realized that i wasn't an ogre
and he said you know i have a very good
friend charlemagne the god have you ever
done this show i said no i'd love to do
a show he said let me set that up we
exchanged information
and i've talked to him twice since then
bill and nothing's happened
um so your point is my point not for
lack of effort right this is what this
is the criticism that guys like you i'd
be delighted to go on the view i'd be
delighted to go on charlemagne the god
i'd be delighted to go on al sharpton
radio show invite me i'm there you went
on mar once but many many years ago
right i've been on mars show in years
because i lit him up when he called
himself a libertarian right you can go
on youtube and look at it and i said
bill you're not a libertarian you
support higher minimum wage you support
a obama obamacare style health care
system uh you don't mind raising taxes i
see the only thing you're libertarian on
is are drugs you're not a libertarian
you're a libertine or a liberal i don't
know what you are but you're not
libertarian he was
not happy with that that was on uh
politically incorrect or real time dude
it was on my radio show it was always on
your radio show yeah yeah
he came on to talk about something else
and i said before we get started we
talked about this and he was livid well
that's the last time i've been on his
show i guess i can say one thing which
is that on i think it's september 20th
or so 21st something like that i'm going
to la i have to go back right to l.a
maybe i'll have lunch with you that'll
be the one joyful thing that i do there
but i'm doing bill maher's podcast so
it's two hours just me and him and you
know i've been very critical of him in a
respectful way i think he's just gotten
to the wrong conclusion i think he's
he's anti-woke he's anti-the gender
stuff he's anti-the race stuff i think
he's realizing stuff about cobit i want
him to get to the end of the road which
is man you got to stop voting for the
democrats you got to stop pretending to
be a progressive he's
if you maybe he can't but i'm going to
try it two hours
one bridge too far he's done he's done i
think you're probably right but i'm
going to try it and i'll do it
respectfully and i i
for even for my frustrations with him
now i admire the guy i think he fought
for what he believed was a a good sane
liberalism in the face of this woke
stuff it didn't work but now you got to
get to the end where the end is hey
larry elder's not my enemy and believe
it or not ted cruz and rand paul aren't
my enemies either sure we have a
different if you want to call out these
democrats who are denying elections call
out uh call out al gore call out hillary
for we've been doing it for four years
call out benny thompson who's denied the
election in ohio be
consistent that's all i want did you see
there was an episode a couple months
back we covered it on my show where he's
going on and on about how great things
are in florida and he's going you know
desantis kept the state open and he's
fighting the woke stuff and the race
stuff and the police are fun to blah
blah blah but then he has to couch it in
but i'm not moving to florida and it's
like well what do you mean so what is it
that you're again is it just because you
really really love abortion which by the
way we have 15 week ban here that's
three and a half months that's a
moderate position florida which is now
thought of like this you know thought of
as a far right red state has a very very
moderate i would argue 15 weeks is far
more moderate than eight month abortions
that california has or nine-month
abortions or post-birth abortions and
murder
um so it's like that's what i want to
get him to it's like wait a minute if if
you're for all of the stuff that a guy
like ron desantis is is trying to get
done is this really because you're still
for the welfare state and high taxes
have you not have we not done that yet
have you not read the thomas soul book
have you not listened to larry elder
long enough and that's what i'm going to
push him on
a few days ago
biden is at a campaign stop
uh
he talked about it i forget the state
and he refers to trump supporters as
believers in
semi-fascism
that's the word he uses semi-fascism
and uh this is his justice department
that's now investigating the former
president wouldn't that be informative
the press secretary was asked about this
uh john karine karine jean-pierre yes i
missed her and she danced around and
danced around and danced around it and
they caught
biden going from the white house to the
helicopter or something and yelled at
him and said what did you mean by
referring to um trump supporters as
semi-fascists and he said
you know what i mean that was it
smiled and said you know what i mean
this is a guy who as you know the reason
he was nominated is because at the very
least they thought he would bring down
the temperature he promised to do that
uh campaign speeches there's no reason
why we can't all get along there's no
blue america there's no right of red
america there's just us we can
and referred to trump supporters as
believers in semi-fascism well i mean
that doesn't surprise me there is
literally nothing the guy could say
either meaningfully
intentionally or unintentionally or
flubbered or whatever that would shock
me at this point i mean they will say
any they need it they need to believe
that
a huge percentage of this country in
essence half of the country are fascists
or evil or nazis or whatever and it's
like man
maybe there's no one that i could
possibly commiserate maybe this is why
we do all this so well together
like of your life
as as a as i always describe you as a
political commentator who happens to be
black your life is a direct example
of it's all a lie when i go to events
with you as i did a year ago basically
this week and there's thousands of
people in a parking lot on a 110 degree
day cheering for you
now a good percentage of them were white
but does that mean that they were white
supremacists who were cheering on the
black guy because they're so evolved
that they figured out
it's all so incredibly stupid but but
they have nothing else what does biden
have to say
what could he say to the country that
would make any sense and be honest and
truthful well he can't defend himself on
crime he can't defend himself on gas
prices he can't defend himself on
inflation he can't put his understanding
he can't defend himself on on what he
did
with afghanistan didn't in my opinion
encourage putin to invade ukraine oh
ukraine happening still it's still good
is that a thing it's still going yeah
that's the thing whatever there's a
there's a ukraine counter-offensive
right now as we speak the russians have
taken over probably the eastern part of
the country uh and we're still sending
billions of dollars there for for aid to
them we're still doing the lion's share
of that not not uh not not the rest of
nato i'm sure we know where that money's
going though right we must have i assume
somebody there's an account somebody
same as we know where all the covet
money was yeah yeah same same guy's
doing that i mean i didn't think of
ukraine once during this month but wait
we just back up for a second on kovid
just real quick so there's some states
doing some something or cities now
there's just some something in there
yeah philadelphia i believe it is has
reimposed the mass mandate what's
interesting about that is in california
a few weeks ago
a few months ago
one of the counties alameda reimposed
the mass mandate the adjacent counties
that are demographically identical did
not which gave us an ideal time to look
at this and find out whether or not it's
going to make any difference it made no
difference whatsoever none
but philadelphia is reimposing a mass
mandate meanwhile a third of the
philadelphia kids k-12 cannot read
at proficiency levels and 20 cannot do
math proficiency levels but they'll be
wearing a mask but they'll be wearing a
mask that's pretty good california the
governor and the state have banned
gasoline-powered cars effective 2035.
and within days of announcing the ban
they urge people with electric cars not
to charge them up during
during uh prime time hours because of uh
because of the stress on the electric
grill on the on the energy grid on the
grid on the grid yeah wow he is batting
banning any edict to ban cars
gas cars by 2035 within days another
edict to not charge your cars up during
certain hours because of the stress on
the grid
you can't make it up
i mean this with love and respect you
can't make it up you prager corolla
do i know anyone else that's sane and
cali i must know somebody everybody else
is gone you're gone what are you doing
shapiro's gone the fact that elon musk
is gone everyone's gone the fact that
that man gavin newsom
has any control over anyone's life who
has systematically destroyed san
francisco as mayor destroyed california
he wants to be president obviously
like he's he wants to push biden out
it's just all so obvious like it's just
right the script is right in front of us
but wait a minute ban gas cards by
twenty three billion dollars
the salary sell the sale of bargaining
as if that will god these virtue
signaling typhoons and now all the tesla
people of la and beverly hills yeah as
if they're gonna not charge their cars
right when they want to you know what i
mean of course not these are the same
people who they they you know they're
forb defunding the police but not the
beverly hills police women when the mob
starts and on my show
like on my epic time show notice i got
that in epic time show epoc agent time
show i've interviewed our engineer named
named ron stein many times
and he's talked about how these
cars are built through
fossil-fueled power
uh the
uh the ingredients in them uh lithium
most notably uh has to be mined in
places like china and chile which
destroys the planet and he says the
impact of electric cars is worse on the
environment than the impact of gasoline
powered cars
tucker carlson did maybe a 10 minute
thing on this just the other day where
he outlined all of the stuff that it
takes to make an electric car and what
it does to the environment and how
little effect it will have on the on the
on the climate it's the first time i've
ever heard anybody do it really in prime
time and it was just massively done wow
and tucker still as a show they didn't
try to they didn't try to lynch them or
axe them or get all the advertisers to
do this and ron stein the engineer i
mentioned believes that it is immoral
for people to drive an electric car for
all those reasons i mentioned not least
of which is where they're doing all this
mining are places where they use a slave
labor
and nobody nobody seems to care so so
the pollution takes place it's not here
in california takes place elsewhere
larry there's a lot of money in china
and it would be good if the nba could
get that money you know
uh brittany greiner speaking of that oh
remains
no she's not she's still behind bars she
received nine years she pled guilty she
apologized and said she inadvertently
packed some
like a vape thing yeah with thc in it
i'm not sure what it is yeah and her
husband her wife says that she would be
out if it had been lebron james so it
wasn't really the
race card since lebron james the black
but it's a sex card it's the sex yeah i
mean it really is a crazy story like
there is a
famous you know rel wnba whatever
there's a level of faith there we can
make all the jokes don't slam with wnba
because i did i got a letter from uh
from a campaign donor yeah whose
daughter works with the league and she
was angry that i had kind of dismissed
the uh
the the league and i said i wasn't
dismissing the leak i just said i don't
watch it i don't mean to dismiss the
league when i hit 50 and i'm retiring
from reuben report i'm throwing on a wig
and i'm going to be in the wnba so you
know i'm not dismissing that um
but if you really think about this story
so she okay she has a vape pen or
something she's in russia and by the way
by the way she left russia
um and
from the time she left the time she came
back the state department put out a
statement and said don't go right
for fearing that maybe people like her
would be nabbed for
political purposes and the russian would
russia would use it because of ukraine
so she went anyway yeah and she brought
the stuff and apparently well she did
plead guilty and her lawyer wrote a
letter of apology so she did apparently
break the law what biden has done
however after initially refusing to do
it is offered her
in exchange for
a guy we have in custody a russian guy
who tried to kill americans who was an
arms dealer and a lot of the
foreign policy people that i watch on
fox say this is an outrageous trade
that you have to trade like for like and
she a violated the law she wasn't a
political prisoner
but b what we're giving up is is too
much and so so far nothing's happened
it's interesting because it's a huge
catch-22 to me you get your citizen back
but i get why that it's not as simple as
that right of course like you do that
and then you encourage them to kidnap
people right it's why you don't
negotiate with terrorists because if you
if you have this huge asset that it
sounds like we have and she's not of
national security interest but she's but
she is a citizen of the united states
that matters to do an asymmetrical trade
sort of doesn't make sense but you but
you do want to get your citizens back so
let's put aside the policy and by the
way she's not the only one that that
they have they have other citizens other
americans who have been in captive
longer what's interesting though to me
is that she is a black lesbian public
person
so this is very high but i never heard
of her until this happened i bet you
hadn't either no i hadn't but and that's
one that's one of the problems when they
made her a call celeb it increased her
value as a token that's what for the
russians so okay all right so you have a
black lesbian let's just put it down
that's a fact you have a black lesbian
this is what the the hierarchy of the
oppression olympics puts at the pinnacle
of this thing in essence is a black
lesbian right she's oppressed by her
skin color she's expressed by her gender
and her sexuality and and she did not
stand for the for the next day she's
during wnbc she's got the whole package
you would think that everyone would be
fighting to free her that the left would
be going bananas that biden would be
bending over backwards to do it because
this is the person he should care about
the most
um but i guess that's just not the case
and they're sort of all bs artists yeah
i bet you i bet you she would love to
hear the national anthem right now
i mean how crazy it really does show you
how weak the united states is like you
could say i'm pretty sure you can say it
plainly which is that if donald trump
was president
brittany greiner would be back already
he would have done something some sort
of deal donald trump or a threat
hopefully or they wouldn't have done it
we would not have had the disastrous
pull out of afghanistan which which
inspired putin to do what he did so this
kind of thing wouldn't have no it's all
it's all connected
um i can't remember where the paulie
pelosi situation was when you left
what paul pelosi got busted for yeah he
got busted for dui that happened right
before i left right what was the status
what's
nothing i think there was like a mug
shot of him and i think that was it well
the uh or he had never been charged
maybe well okay okay well he was since
charged okay uh but the video was not
released now over the years i've watched
a lot of people get busted famous people
get busted i remember the uh
the manager of oakland uh uh athletics
yeah he got busted and they put out the
the video of him you know mumbling and
stumbling and i've seen other
celebrities get busted and they put out
the video but we never saw the paula
pelosi video until after the plea deal
and it has been a plea deal
and the deal basically is he gets a
some community service
five days in jail which are suspended
because of something or other slap on
the wrist he also by the way he does
have to live the rest of his life with
nancy pelosi which is a certain type of
punishment we also found out though that
when he got busted he produced he's
fumbling he can't do any he can't he
can't he won't take a breathalyzer yeah
he produces a card
that you get if you donate a hundred
thousand dollars or more to the police
and flashed it
and um it appeared to be
not a bribe but yeah but i i'm he also
he also said i'm a high profile person
he said that
and tried to get a pass and they didn't
give him a pass the cops didn't yeah but
the d.a claims that she did it by the
book uh but a lot of us meaning on our
side believe she did not do it by the
book and then and that the video was not
released the way it often is on other
people and larry has there been a theme
of double standards has there been a
theme of they can do it and they'll
always do it and they'll always get away
with it and we do have to point it out
it's important to point it out and note
it and mock it and the rest of it as i
said earlier but it won't stop it so if
you have that side doing that you know
that that chaos and that endless lie
this this nonsensical endless lie that's
always existing here
to me you can be part of it at some
level but you got to extricate yourself
and you got to go do other things again
that that really is it's where i've been
at for a long time but by the way it
wasn't a minor fender bender there was a
substantial amount of damage uh pelosi
could have killed somebody and the
person that he that he whose car he
struck
on the video he's speaking spanish
uh i have no idea what he's saying
um and i don't know whether he's in the
country even legally
my suspicion is i could be wrong that he
was an illegal alien and that's one of
the reasons why um
paulie pelosi was able to get off so
easily and this had been eulets that he
ran into
uh and it was his fault
uh i think you had made a big stink out
of it what's an illegal alien gonna
gonna say right
but again i'm not sure whether the guy
was an illegal alien that hasn't been
determined one way or the other yet
right well you would think that'll break
at some point right i mean they'll do
their darndest to hide it if he's
illegal
um first lady dr jill biden yes she's
still a doctor performing those
surgeries is positive for covert 19
again she's got it too yeah
despite being a doctor despite being a
doctor jeez are they still like they're
still trying to get everybody vaxxed and
all of the stuff it's only like they
still so fauci's on his way out that's
great speaking of
a vouch of of fouchy uh joe rogan also
getting back to him for a second uh he
had uh a guest on i think of him in
minute and um they were talking about
covet shutting everything down and how
the
organization cdc mandated this and the
other
and now we're finding out that the
lockdown bad idea finding out that uh
regular immunity uh natural immunity is
stronger uh finding out that the
vaccines for young people were probably
pointless because young people don't get
it
and rogan said when asked what's oh he's
talking to aaron rodgers the quarterback
of the quarterback of the uh the packers
and rogers says what's the answer and uh
rogan said vote republican oh he did so
he's really getting there so he's ready
his red peeling has been really nice
because it's taken him a while let's not
forget this this guy was a you know he
was very conflicted about his views i
think in a lot of ways and everyone is
to some extent when you're waking up
because the guy was a bernie supporter
who then left california for tax
purposes so it's like you got to piece
these things together man you can say
i'm a nice bernie supporter socialist
and i like all this stuff i don't want
to pay taxes but i don't want to pay
taxes so i'm moving to texas
so his you know this is this is sort of
similar to right before i left he said
that he was going to vote for desantis
so that's great because he he's got real
influence and if you think about it
there's not a lot of people that could
move politically right you got your
people that are hardcore republicans
let's say and hardcore democrats i think
the sliver of people that could move are
the disaffected libs it is the the bill
maher rogenesque it's those libs that
are just like a couple years maybe
behind where i was that those are the
ones that can still
be shifted let's say so that that's
great to hear
um speaking of of rogers he was very
critical of the nfl
and he called him stooges
for mandating all of this uh
all these rules and regulations good um
joker this novak djokovic
is not going to be playing in this
year's u.s open because he refuses to
get vaccinated they're still still doing
that now you can go and watch the us
open not being vaccinated and if you're
born in america and have not been
vaccinated you can play but because he
is a foreigner and because the cdc
requires anybody coming in from out of
the country to be vaccinated he cannot
play in the u.s is that right that
that's still a thing
so right now if you were to come to the
united states
on vacation you have to be back i think
so
jeez i think so
the vaccine which uh will stop and or
prevent the spread of kovid until it
doesn't we're on we're on tennis um
serena williams yeah has announced her
last tournament
u.s open
she
played her first round she won
and the stadium was packed uh second
round she won just uh i think it was
yesterday yesterday the day before and
the stadium's packed
and she is now getting the kind of
treatment that i recall um
uh
wasn't john mc john mcenroe but another
uh major player oh uh connors
yeah i remember that
aaron crickstein
and he went pretty deep into the thing
yeah that was 92 39 years old yeah she's
older than he was oh is that right yeah
he's she's 41 i think yeah and it's
she's getting the same kind of reaction
oh people are going nuts that's nice you
know what's funny about her is you've
seen the interview with her and
letterman about men's and women's tennis
there's an interview it's from about i
don't know maybe eight years ago where
she's on letterman and talk and he's
asking her but you know could you beat a
guy could you beat um you know federer
or one of these guys and she's like
men's and women's tennis aren't even the
same sport they would crush me it
wouldn't last 10 seconds yeah i think
she said the top the 100th guy 100th men
right could be could be could be the
best woman right so i guess she's
a misogynist
uh nancy pelosi
announced her
desire to go to taiwan
there is a fear right now that china is
going to invade taiwan china has always
had a one china policy and believes
taiwan is part of china yeah but nancy
pelosi announced her attention to go to
taiwan
uh and
some members of the white house
apparently did not want her to go
but she went anyway
and there was some controversy before
she went and the feeling was once you
say you're gonna go
just because china and china puts out
some statement they were very angry
about it once you say you're going to go
you can't let china right
dictate who goes and who doesn't go
because we've had
government officials going to go to
taiwan for years right so uh pelosi went
and came back and now a couple of
republicans are going but there's a real
fear right now that china is about ready
this close to invading taiwan
i mean that's
that's like world altering stuff people
i don't think people fully understand
the and if if china does invade taiwan
what should we do if anything is my
question to you
i think
this i mean this is mostly where my
libertarian side side says we can't do
much we can turn some screws on some
economic stuff
you know i'm not a big tariff guy like
there's not that like we can't get into
a military confrontation halfway across
the world
um even though i absolutely believe that
taiwan is entitled to being a sovereign
nation and all that stuff i don't know
what what do you think what do you think
i mean well i certainly don't think we
have the more with this buffoon as
president and and nancy pelosi and the
rest of these clowns it's like we don't
we don't have the moral authority
nor the nor the sort of
technical capability to lead the the
bottom line is if
china invades taiwan we're not going to
do anything yeah what are we going to do
go to war right
even though there's a tree that
obligates us to do it we're not going to
do that so it almost doesn't matter what
i think ought to happen we're not going
to do it yeah but i do want to comment
what you said about your libertarian
instincts there isn't any libertarian
kind of foreign policy that i know of um
a lot of people think libertarians all
believe that we all never intervene in
anything like full isolation i don't
believe that there is a libertarian
doctrine regarding foreign policy right
that i can that i can determine although
i know a lot of people feel that way
right
ron paul was a libertarian and didn't
want to intervene in almost anything and
so therefore people assume that every
libertarian feels that way they don't
i'm not quite sure uh what the
libertarian worldview is right i know
the libertarian worldview is regarding
domestic policy which is government
should be small and unobtrusive and
it will get off my back i know the main
libertarian policy is that if you get 10
libertarians around a table you're going
to argue about
driver's licenses for about seven hours
that's the main thing growing
number of people believe now that the
likelihood of taking back both the house
and the senate
is not good there are at least four
senate races is not good it's not good
uh house still good yeah but there are
four senate races where the republican
candidate is is losing um
uh arizona's one of them so blake
masters is losing to uh
gifford's husband uh mark whatever um
ohio yeah uh so that's jd not going well
um
pennsylvania yeah that's awesome
uh and georgia herschel walker they're
all underwater right now not underwater
but but um beyond the margin of error
right and there's a chance that all four
could lose and mitch mcconnell has now
said
that um we should change our
expectations he didn't say it quite that
way and he said it's because of
candidate quality
indicate suggesting that these these
candidates i think all of them have been
backed that's a trump donald trump right
so that's a that's a mcconnell going
after trump yeah it looks like it well
mcconnell in a weird way might want them
all to lose because if they all won
those are all trump backhanded it's i
happen blake i know i consider him a
friend he's a good guy he would join me
on tour just like you did
he would be a great senator and he's a
good human being i've interviewed jd
oz it's a little hard to tell like what
he really is and hershel walker i don't
know personally but you know seems like
a good guy but you could see why
mcconnell as a mcconnell's the ultimate
swamp creature right so why would he
want trump back candidates that he can't
control
so you could sort of see that um but
does it feel a little bit like a hearing
you say that it sounds a little bit like
a media make-believe story like all the
trump people are going to lose and then
everyone will be caught with their pants
down in two months
it's this it's the media happy to watch
the trump people win primaries but then
lose the general and that seems to be
the kind of
thing that people on the left are happy
about uh i'm not quite sure what
mitchell's thing is i think what
mitchell is doing is saying don't blame
me if we don't take back the senate
right interesting i mean look
it's september 1st the election is still
you know two two weeks and or two months
and a week away basically so anything
can happen i wouldn't get too worried
about that but are generally is is the
feeling still that that the house will
be taken yeah yeah although although
they gotta go there
sarah palin lost her race
uh for the house it's unexpected let's
go and again uh in november uh for the
full seat uh but she lost the seat that
would be held from now until november
but she's running again in november but
she did lose
what do you the general i asked you at
the beginning when you told me about the
trump thing um what do you feel like the
general temperature of the country is
right now does it feel crazier than it
felt
sort of a month and a half ago
no you know it's hard to imagine that
things ever get that the pressure
release ever valves off so that the
temperature goes down but does it seem
or does it seem roughly the same well
here's my thing when when people were
saying it's a slam dunk we're going to
take back the senate and the house
i never felt that way and the reason i
never felt that way is because anything
that joe biden does if he expels gas in
the pantry oh it smelled like perfume so
he signs this bill this skinny uh build
back better bill yeah he does the
student debt thing
uh and these are called republi democrat
victories by the media
uh one of my friends is a guy named tim
grossclose he's professor professor
at
george mason university used to be at
ucla
he wrote a book called left turns we
talked about this before
and he tried to quantify the effect the
left-wing media has on votes
and based on some experimentation his
conclusion is that leftwing media gives
the democrat 10 points out of the gate
and so anything that happens between now
and the election time that is perceived
at all beneficial for joe biden as when
there was a zero percent
inflation increase in july as the gas
prices are coming down a little bit
um they're going to call this right his
plans his plans are working they dropped
60
it's like well but they had gone up 215
before that but you know i wrote about
this in my last book i mean it's a
little bit like plato's the cave if
you're if you just exist in the cave and
that's all the information that you have
and that's what a lot of people have and
that still is our job is to keep
breaking
the the
ice that exists around people that all
of the nonsense that they have been lied
to and lied by it's why that video that
you and i did way back when when you
when you smacked me senseless when i
didn't even know uh you know we didn't
know each other personally at that point
um it's why that video has now been seen
probably it might be 50 million times
the amount of ways it's been cut and and
people saw me breaking out of the ice
and that's what we got to keep doing
there is a video of governor gavin
newsom at the white house
uh this is when bide was out of the
country yes i saw that that was right
before i look okay yeah i mean and the
speculation is as you pointed out that
uh that news may run for off and i want
to talk to you a little bit about that
because let me tell you what i think is
going to happen
the
democrats are stuck with kamala harris i
mean stuck with her the reason she was
chosen because she clicked all the boxes
she tried to run for president and this
scuttlebutt is that her numbers are so
bad they're under joe biden that they
have to drop kick her are you kidding me
democrats are the most loyal part of the
blacks are the most important part of
the democratic base and black females
are the most loyal part of that
and i read a lot of black media
publications like the griot and when
kamala harris was mocked for her cackle
and for her doing nothing about
determining the root causes of illegal
immigration
they reacted with that was trivial the
reason they're laughing at her is
because she's a black female and joe
biden's giving her crappy jobs and how
dare they
supplant her with a
man
especially a white man
and so my feeling is that if kamala
harris wants the job and she does
if they drop kick her
black females will be livid and they are
important in the alabama georgia and
south carolina primaries almost half of
the democrat voters in those primaries
are blacks you think they would be they
will be so angry they will sit home they
won't vote republican but yeah the ghost
at home yeah which will ensure the
defeat of the democrat nominee in 2024
no matter who we put up against him or
her yeah so so they're stuck with her
it's a it's a good example of why making
a deal with the devil rarely works out
because they made a deal with the devil
with her right you take this mentally
compromised completely
swamp written 47-year politician in
biden who everyone knows is nothing of
what he used to be you throw in the the
diversity check with her because that's
all she was i i don't mean that because
i care about race or gender but it's
simply the truth she was polling at zero
you know this larry she was polling at
zero in her own party when she dropped
out of the race right well she wanted
zero she dropped out before the first
contest yeah yeah she did what she do
she did one or two debates where they
they the media loved her the media loved
her but remember when tulsi really
smacked her down never recovered from
that no so she has no real support but
you make a deal with the devil the deal
with the devil that the democrats made
is oh we can call we can and it's like
who is this i'm not totally sure is it
clinton somehow still or is it obama or
whatever but the deal was basically
we're going to have this mentally
compromised president joe biden that
will appear to be a moderate but will
usher in all the lunacy then we're going
to bring in this black woman that if you
criticize her you're going to be
considered a racist or a misogynist and
then i don't think they thought he was
going to break down this quickly i think
that that's the i don't think they're
flying in the ointment i don't know i
don't think they care they wanted
[Music]
make sure that trump did not win after
that we'll figure it out so what do you
think they're going to do
they're going to they're going to run
kamala harris they have no choice so you
think biden i'm still i still buy buyers
into this thing i i
yeah the question is what happens in
2024 and the answer is they are stuck
with kamala harris they cannot get rid
of her uh they will if they try to do so
it will be perceived as both sexist and
racist and black female voters will
simply stay home and and they can't
afford it so you rushed they started
kamala harris gavin newsom the ticket
from hell
well
i'm not sure about gavin newsom right
two people from california two left-wing
people from california i don't think
that's going to work um
but at the top of the ticket will be
comment harris if uh joe biden does not
make it to 2024 and i don't see how he
can right did anything else happen in
terms of uh republicans announcing they
were running for president has anyone
announced no no this this the
scuttlebutt was that trump wouldn't
would announce right so i guess that
means
then the mar-a-lago rate happened i'm
not saying he was going to i'm just
saying that raid happened and so now the
feeling is trump will probably wait
until the midterms are over before he
announces but who knows you know i just
remembered the last time i saw you was
not in california
i saw you at mar-a-lago for the 2000
mules premiere were you there when the
guy fell in the pool it's pretty great i
heard about it okay
a guy just having a drink standing on
the side of the massive pool there's
thousands of people there out in tuxedos
guy just takes a spill into the pool
pretty soon yeah it might have been a
plant
um a bunch of companies are
talking about hiring freezes
amazon apple ford jpmorgan lift
microsoft meta which is facebook netflix
uh stubhub sub stack tesla twitter
wayfair all announcing
hiring freezes
wow uh let me say something about sub
stack real quick you know what's you
know about sub stack so substack is
where a lot of independent writers are
now going uh because you can basically
have your own paywall so where locals
does video subset does written word so a
lot of people have gone there
as of this morning since i'm in the
local studios i can say this we now have
all the functionability the
functionality of substack on local so
you can fully do all of your articles
there and everything else so we're
really going all in on this that's why
i'm very proud to be here in the studio
that we create and everything else well
no that doesn't surprise me well wait so
is the economy still not going great is
that not going great
how much number one issue while we're
being self-serving yeah my documentary
uncle tom
yes wait we came out in august right
came out august 26th yeah oh just a
couple days ago yeah thank you and uh
it's available on uncle tom.com
uh by the way we're letting letting
people watch the first one for free on
uncle tom.com because
the first one
as you know when you do a documentary
any kind of movie in hollywood if you do
three times it's cost that's considered
to be a hit
uncle tom generated 10 times its cost
has a higher imdb rating than any of the
ones that was nominated for the for best
documentary in 2024 you don't say i
don't say uh imdb rating of 8.4 right
now as we speak uh uncle tom won
and to give you some perspective those
who aren't familiar with imdb ratings um
casablanca has a 8.5 which america's
so it really has done well
and right now uh there are about 29 30
reviews of uncle tom 2 on imdb and and
it's got a 9.9 rating the reviews have
been off the chart and i've had
premieres in phoenix and in dallas one
in l.a and
people are just going crazy it's it's
it's a godfather too yeah it's better
than the first one the first one was
really good oh i'm thrilled to hear that
and uh obviously i'll promote the hell
out of it and good for you and that's
that's what we have to do right that's
not just exposing the hypocrisy that's
then building something new here's a new
way of looking at this stuff by the way
speaking of movies i did watch one well
i watched a bunch of old movies you know
while doing cardio or whatever but i did
watch top gun i was going to ask tell
you about that top gun is now
the seventh or eighth highest grossing
movie ever is that right yes i loved it
ever it was did you see it yes it was so
refreshing and it didn't hate america
and there was no social justice and it
was about accomplishing something and
you know melding the past with the
future and the present and tom cruise i
don't know what the hell they're
injecting him with but the guy looks
pretty freaking good for his he's like
87 years old who was his love interest
in the first one what's her name uh uh
gene trebelhorn so i don't know no yeah
mcginnis kelly oh kelly mcginnis sorry
yeah okay she was asked
why you weren't invited to do this one i
can see the she said have you seen how i
look
because my guess is she's 70 or
something and well that's whatever age
she is same age as crews right
but it wouldn't work it would say have
you seen me that's funny wow it was so
refreshing to see a movie that was
actually it's not even that it was pro
america it just was it just was real and
it feel like accomplishment it had heart
it had it i liked it more than the first
one yeah so i really liked it yeah i
hadn't seen the first one until i saw
the second one because i wanted
something interesting i saw the first
one right before i saw the second one a
few days before and i went huh yeah it's
okay but i didn't love the first one the
way everyone did yeah so i was playing
but isn't that interesting like the
state of hollywood that when something
is good it's it's shocking to you at
this point if you go to a new movie or
you hear new music and you go it's
actually good that there there's a shock
level there where back in the day
it's like when either one of us were
growing up right it's like when you were
growing up in the 70s i'm growing up in
the 80s it's like
every day there was something new that
was great a new sitcom a new album i
grew up in the 60s
thank you i appreciate it i appreciate
that yeah i appreciate that
but you know what i mean like all right
born in the 50s man the 60s so in the
60s every day there was another amazing
song that was hitting number one on the
charts almost every day right where now
it's like anything that's new that's
good you're kind of shocked you know
when you turn up you watch i shut off
top gun and i was like wow i wasn't
angry it actually didn't insult me i
felt it was entertaining like pretty
good
on the hollywood front um
jon stewart
he's back well he's
back in the news there was a there was a
bill to provide money for uh members of
our armed services who were exposed to
toxic substances yeah this is he's been
fighting for this right for a long time
he's been held up held up held up and
there is video of him
confronting a uh black a uh a white uh
white it doesn't matter what his race is
a a conservative named jack
jackson okay
i know yeah and uh for some reason
prosopia
came to whatever this this event was
that stewart was doing out outside where
he talked about this bill and they
started yelling at each other
and from what i could tell both of them
supported the bill
wasn't supported paying off paying armed
services for being exposed to toxic
substances
but
stuart and he just went at it and my
feeling is that what uh prosobiac was
basically saying is legislation often is
saddled with a bunch of nonsense and a
stripped down bill both sides would
would would sign up on and ultimately
there was a strip down bill that both
sides did come to agreement on and joe
biden signed it but for whatever reason
they were yelling at each other
over this huh
i guess i guess i would need a little
more would did i take it it caught fire
if john stewart's yelling at somebody
yeah because he was
interviewed and he talked about how
congress is dragging its feet and these
people are dying and
and i didn't know that much about the
bill all i do know about congress i know
how it works and often times stuff is
vote voted down
because the other side puts on writers
and other stuff so it's not a clean bill
and so it got voted down because it
wasn't a clean bill both sides perceived
the other side to be playing games but i
knew ultimately it would pass ultimately
it did so i'm not quite sure why john
stewart felt the need to yell and scream
at this guy because of this but huh i
mean
look
the bigger issue since i don't know all
the specifics on that the bigger issue
is they got to stop tacking on all of
this other nonsense all these bills
imagine if we just had clean bills hey
this is a clean water bill this is what
it's going to be it's not also about
giving paraplegic lesbians the right to
play volleyball on the moon which that's
coming i would imagine
are you following monkey parks
oh well does everyone here have monkey
pox is it
do you got the pox well um
is it california huge california had to
scare declared a state of emergency over
the monkey pox outbreak
it turns out larry you don't from what
i've read about 98 of those who get
monkey pox are men having sex with men
yeah
they develop a vaccine for it just like
that though there's no vaccine available
for it like a vaccine vaccine or a
vaccine like a covered vaccine like holy
vaccine oh so not saying that works i
don't have no idea i just know it was
developed real fast all of a sudden
monkey pox comes out and suddenly
there's a vaccine which kind of
surprised me i believe that the last
thing i said to my crew before we went
off the grid was uh when i'm gone guys
uh no having sex with random strangers
in alleyways and that still stands it's
like if you don't want monkey bugs don't
bang a monkey and don't have sex with a
whole bunch of strangers
but they they did that controversial
they did not ban any kind of outdoor
gatherings
among gays yeah and so there is some
feeling that the way they're dealing
with this outbreak is different than the
way they're dealing with other outbreaks
oh
because of the political correct nature
right well you know i had well david
horowitz who of course you know i had
david horowitz on years ago and he said
something really fascinating to me that
i think stands to to your point on
monkey pox he said that when he was in
the in new york city in the 80s
and he was just starting to become a
conservative so he you know this is a
lefty communist he's now he's now
starting to become a republican or
whatever you want to call it that the
aids crisis is breaking out and they
knew where the aids crisis was spreading
they knew it was happening at these bath
houses right you know these guys i mean
this is also why you want equality if
you have people that can only meet in
underground bars and clubs and whatever
then it's going to breed a certain
amount of promiscuity and whatever but
he said that the republicans in new york
city because they knew that it was
happening at these gay bath houses
aids that's where it was spreading like
crazy the republicans wanted to close
down the bath houses he said that it was
the democrats that wouldn't let it
because they said you're homophobes so
the democrats actually and this is
exactly what you're talking about with
monkeypox it's the same thing in the
interest of oh everyone behavior doesn't
matter and everyone
can live however they want and blah blah
blah you actually end up killing the
people that you're purporting to protect
right so i'm not surprised by that at
all are you following the kerry lake
gubernatorial race in arizona yeah well
i've had carrie on the show i like her a
lot um i i hope she wins um i was just
in phoenix and i was standing at a sign
for her and
she had a picture of trump next to her
and was called trump back candidate my
understanding of talking to people in
phoenix is that many of the signs have
been sabotaged have been vandalized
because she's referred to herself as a
trump-backed candidate
as you know she was a anchor very
popular for years in phoenix and got out
of the business because she thought it
was just too one-sided she couldn't do
it anymore
interesting so well she is a trump
backhanded for sure right he has he has
officially endorsed it so so did my pack
elder for america we endorsed her too
good good good by the way larry elder
i feel like your political future's not
hey not over you just have that glow
well you know you know when women get
pregnant there's a glow you've got the
glow i'm just well i'm not pregnant i
tell you that
but i am considering um
doing something down the road uh i i'm
not ready to make any kind of
announcement but i am thinking about
maybe running for uh for a higher office
what's higher than governor of
california
head of the penitentiary in california i
don't know
something about it
i wanted to ask you about
for for some reason this is your staff
not me because i didn't even know about
this guy
kim kardashian and pete davidson have
officially called it quits
could not care less and whoever put that
in the run down this fight
could not care less i had to look to see
who he was yeah long time snl guy he was
actually
here
but i did a wiki on him his father was
killed 911 father was a firefighter
charging up the stairs wow he was killed
and he was about eight years old or so
and uh
he says he's never been quite the same
but i had no idea that they were they
were together for nine months which for
for california is kind of a old marriage
um and they've now broken up wow well
so that was what you held you held that
one to the yeah to the very
by the way the kardashians have said
something about his um
equipment the size of
his equipment oh for some reason that's
been in the news i don't know i asked my
girlfriend about it she she knew about
it good or not good you know
depends depends
we are still sending money to ukraine
another 5.5 billion nonsense absolute
nonsense absolute nonsense i interviewed
rand paul right before i went off the
grid a couple days before rand paul rand
paul and all he all he said was hey we
just want some he's like i'm not voting
for it but you know could we at least
get some numbers on this thing can
anyone break it down what is this money
going to is there any tracking of any
other they don't track anything before
the invasion there were a bunch of
articles in the new york times about how
corrupt
ukraine is and how they have all these
oligarchs who spend all the money then
all of a sudden uh it was a great
country with this wonderful democracy
and we have to get behind 100 percent
yeah and we're still sending our
celebrities there to take pictures with
uh what's his name and
uh we talked earlier about tulsi gabbard
yeah um what do you think her future is
she set in for the tucker carlson show
recently did you yeah look first off i
like her a lot i like her personally i
know her a bit off camera i've
interviewed her several times she is a
good human being and just imagine why
she still a democrat well just imagine
had the democrats at the end when when
by when they handed it to biden and they
made all the backdoor deals and gay pete
and everybody when they all left after
right before super tuesday imagine if
tulsi who stayed in because she's not
part of the machine imagine if biden had
been like you know what i'm going to go
with this tulsi girl and she's actually
an active member of the military and she
loves america and she's not about
identity politics and blah blah i think
how different the country could
potentially be her sitting in for for uh
tucker
i don't know that that that she wants to
be a tv star in that regard but i think
she's an important voice and i think
she's she is a crossover
type person she's the type of person
that i referenced earlier the sort of
disaffected liberal that
is basically ready to vote republican
but doesn't they either don't want to
say it publicly or they don't know how
to quite get there she's the type it's
why i'm always putting the pressure on
mar it's like there's a couple people
that can help lead these people to the
promise promise land maybe that's sort
of what you did a long time ago it's
what i've done over a couple years right
and and people need somebody to kind of
map it for them so when rogan who is not
a traditional republican he is not
religious or whatever when he you know
he's a pot-smoking mushroom-eating
ayahuasca doing
mma fighting you know blah blah it's
like when he says hey i could be
conservative
it's like there's something there
there's something powerful there tulsi
that would be great so i don't know i
don't know that but that's interesting
that's interesting uh let's let's finish
up with with uh with kovid uh
the superintendent of schools in excuse
me the mayor of dc
says unvaccinated students are banned
from in-person learning
that's muriel bowser yeah i believe her
name is don't like her who's very
unhappy about the busload of illegal
aliens yeah that we ship them you know
we ship them from florida governor of
florida and texas have been shipping up
there yeah pretty sweet but what a great
policy so you enter the country without
being vaccinated that's okay yeah but
you can't go to school if you haven't
been vaccinated i mean that's just it's
profoundly evil um i think you could
argue
in that they frame everything through
racism you probably could argue it's
racist because there's a certain amount
of black people who don't trust the
system well
a larger percentage of blacks are not
being vaccinated yep than than whites
and so she doesn't want young black kids
it's kind of interesting because the
left of course
tells blacks that they are victims of
stomach racism
while telling them to trust the
government when they promote this
vaccine and so you're shocked that a lot
of black people are are skeptical the
government is an evil systemically
racist patriarchy and it just needs your
money to get more done that's the thing
with the government that's the thing
with the government
and uh these kids again are denied a
whole year of in-person education a
whole year
there was a study done a few years ago
85 percent of black 8th graders 13 13
year old people uh cannot read or do
math at proficiency levels and they lost
a whole year of in-person education and
suicides have gone up the black
community depression's gone up drug
abuse has gone up we think child abuse
has gone up i say we think because we
don't know because the number one way of
reporting that is teachers when the kids
go to school they didn't go to school
for a whole year so we don't know we
assumed the other things went up why
wouldn't that go up as well
we got work to do who is it that says we
got a country to save there's somebody
and when i was running for governor i
was asked about vaccine
mandates and i said i've been vaccinated
because of my age because i've got
underlying
things high blood pressure among other
things
but i don't believe that young people
should be vaccinated i think that young
healthy people not likely to get sick
not likely to get really sick not likely
to go to the hospital not likely to die
cnn interviewed me for about a half hour
on all of this and they played
two minutes of what i said and they
didn't snip it up but they played what i
said i said what i just now said
and then joe john's the correspondence
but that's not true according to the cdc
blah blah blah blah blah now it's coming
out everything i said was accurate
man they just they lie and lie and lie
and we know they're lying and they know
they're lying and they know we know
they're what they've done to the economy
what they've done to learning what
they've done to businesses about a third
of all the restaurants in california are
now gone forever and most of them owned
by mom and pops black and brown people
the people that they claim they care
about you don't have to go back to
california we're here in miami man i got
a great real estate agent what are you
doing stay here with me come on man they
probably won't let me back in
[Laughter]
uh larry i thank you for uh for doing
this was perfect absolutely appreciate
it you are you are a true pro i said to
my guys when we were going through the
list of who could bring me back well i
appreciate it who is a pro do you know
anything as i'm doing this as i say
again it's a lot of pressure because
i've got to give you the facts so you
can respond properly as opposed to when
we're done you go elder said this that's
that's not what happened
the the mar-a-lago thing in particular
yeah it's got a lot of angles to it a
lot of wrinkles to it and i'm trying to
give you the exactly what happened so
you can respond properly to it
larry i thank you very much my pleasure
uh i should also note that i'm going to
do a locals exclusive live stream to
talk a little bit more about the
personal stuff the parenting and did i
even say my son's name did i even say it
you said jason uh justin justin did i
say jason i think that might be the
other one okay maybe you've just
revealed too much all right i think it's
justin uh but yes where's the camera or
i'll just talk to you um yeah i'm gonna
do another locals exclusive live stream
ruben report dilocals.com at uh 2 p.m 2
p.m eastern so in just a little bit and
take a little break i'll even buy you
lunch and then you're going back to cali
going back yes sucker what are you doing
somebody has to do it
thank you my friend they're not going to
chase me
out we'll continue